[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link joining us today at the round
table of dim lighting is improv comedian
YouTube creator co-creator of one of the
most popular YouTube series of all time
epic Rap Battles of History that's right
lloyd ahlquist AKA epiclloyd we are very
excited about this one
because as you might have known we
mainly pin in a cap on these epic Rap
Battles of History or sound like you're
bragging this is my humble brag voice I
hate to admit it but we've been in three
epic rap battles you know the thing we
love these guys both Pete and Lloyd you
know we talked to Pete on last season of
ear biscuits and now we get to talk to
the other half to Lloyd we love these
guys be cut for you know they're great
guys nice Peter really is nice and Lloyd
is really epic he's also very nice
yeah he's epically nice but what if what
if he was called epic nice Lloyd like
though he was trying to one-up not very
weird and it wouldn't be very nice with
it but one of the reasons we love these
guys is because I love to get involved
in something that I know is going to be
great yeah you know we spend all this
time trying to get our videos the way we
want them to be and then we're still not
satisfied 90% of the time but there's so
many times when you kind of get involved
in somebody else's project you're kind
of like well I kind of think you should
doing like this but I'm not gonna speak
up I'm not gonna say anything these guys
knock it out of the park every single
time like link said one of the most
successful I probably the most
successful series and in terms of a
series of this type definitely the most
successful musical series ever on the
youtubes yeah and of course we were
recently featured as Lewis and Clark in
the latest in one of the latest rap
battles did you hear that Meriwether I
think I mean a brawl so here's a clip of
that
[Music]
so we had a great conversation with
Lloyd he's already a good friend of ours
whenever we get to hangout guesting on a
spot like that right so you're gonna get
to hear the lloyd half of the story of
how this all came together with epic rap
battles of history and just Lloyd's
background in general a lot of people
don't know that he didn't just start
with improv comedy but he's continued
with that and actually has a hand in an
improv comedy theater here in Los
Angeles yeah and I really enjoyed
picking his brain about improv comedy he
said he wants to write a book about it
that's how passionate he is about it it
was like a formula yeah he has a formula
so that amongst the whole backstory of
epic rap battles and the organic yes I
use the term wave it that kind of came
about right it's very fascinating so
stick around for that you will enjoy it
we want to let you guys know if you
didn't already we just released an album
called song biscuits volume 1 released
it on iTunes last week as you know if
you watch the good mythical morning
channel for the past few months on
Saturday we have been doing a song
biscuit an original song based on your
suggestions oftentimes a collaboration
with another youtuber and these songs
were conceptualized and then written and
performed all in about an hour or so and
but you know it tended to be a great set
of 15 different songs that you can go by
individually on iTunes or you can get
the entire album for a whole album in 99
899 I think it is also available through
Amazon if you are not an iTunes person
yeah so support our mythical endeavors
by downloading that album and spend more
time with us in year
in your ears in between these ear
biscuits and we may or may not be
animating a few of those I'm not gonna
say well I'm gonna just got the scoop on
ear biscuits we are gonna be doing that
we also want to mention our sponsor EF
College break you know we've talked
about them a few times the travel
experts at EF College break make travel
easy affordable and even more fun for
anyone ages 18 to 28 college not
required here's the thing when you make
the decision to travel and to plan it
all yourself you may end up like the guy
who recently wanted to plan a trip to
Grenada but he actually planned a trip
to Grenada yeah they sound the same but
one is in Spain and one is in the
Caribbean and he wanted to go to the one
in Spain well it okay I thought you goes
the one is in the Carib Caribbean and
one is in a prison you know what he did
he sued the airline then he sue the
airline after accidentally going to the
Caribbean if you go remember that the
one with the ease in Spain in the month
or I don't know the one without the sea
I don't know I could go to either one
right now I would be happy but North is
gonna give college break the point is is
that why try to do this I'm actually I'm
planning a you know I'm not 18 to 28 I'm
too older than that but I'm just trying
to plan a little anniversary trip with
my wife to Santa Barbara and I can't
figure out what to do there if I could
have any money to go overseas you're not
right you want to try to make a real
trip happen across a continent you need
help with that brothers and sisters yeah
they have the options they have the
expertise
check out their website they've built
trips across six continents including a
grand tour of Ireland Costa Rican
Adventure Bay and a road trip through
Europe and they provide a tour director
who's also a local expert so you don't
get egg on your face unless that's the
tour the egg on your face tour we don't
have that it is not an option and don't
worry about signing it by yourself
because you won't be alone if you sign
up you will get group together with
other people that you will like and
enjoy traveling with well I can't make
that promise but if you're open-minded
maybe so do it head over to our special
URL EF College break.com slash
rhettandlink we will hook you up with a
hundred dollars off your next adventure
that's right hundred dollars off EF
College break.com slash rhett and Link
and now onto the biscuit thanks for
coming to the round table dim lighting
Boyd my very much my pleasure you're
late but that's okay I know I'm very
let's start with that so sorry I'm in
traffic there what's your la excuse I
feel like it's so we're so far apart you
can't I know I'm having this
conversation
I'm also talking to you as if like
people are listening which they are but
like it always changes it does a little
bit my dad used to have this businessman
voice on the phone you back this
Burroughs Alex he would be like Bruce
all quest and here at toggling baggage
was he what was he he was an Elvis
impersonator so I was late because we
were Harper trying to do something else
yeah he's like a like a handyman Carbon
dare plumber or whatever you want to do
my dad does some of that stuff too I
always say my wife has a very like super
sweet phone voice and then she'll like
turn to me and it's like a totally
different that phone voice I mean that
sweet phone voice I definitely change
the tone of my voice when I'm like
assuming a certain status you know like
if you have to sound like you're in
charge or or if you're like having to
sound like you're be you know
charismatic or whatever but right now
you sound like the friend Lloyd and
that's what we want okay well don't
bring out the enemy Lloyd because I yeah
did you ever have one of those friends
who started talking lower but you could
tell he was trying to talk lower leg in
puberty
years yeah we're like why it's just
happened in my high school we have a
couple friends no no names will be named
Bill who like we went to high school
with them in a psalm like a couple years
after high school and he was like
talking like this really trying to talk
low now
I don't know any babies in there I
definitely like if I'm talking like like
I don't know I talk like more hood if
I'm hanging around with like a bunch of
mic my hood friends or whatever so right
I go more southern yeah like even when I
just said my dad I said dad yeah and it
was almost that bad my diet because
that's how I saw he kind of talks my dad
he doesn't affect his voice when he's
talking on the phone like your dad but
he can't get off the phone that's the
thing my dad has is at the end of the
phone conversation when you're just
supposed to say bye yeah my dad's one
more thing
mm-hmm okay he doesn't sing English
either he speaks in alien language that
is a Long Goodbye like like you're me
we're like okay dad look okay dad love
you thanks a lot for the call okay all
right okay thanks what you well you
cannot yep we've got to go no I on the
phone oh yeah not good okay that I came
back he let me listen to it one time
there she put it on speaker I was like
no cuz he had told me this I was like
there's no way that he did just what you
just and he doesn't start anything it's
just at the end of a conversation is
yeah that's got to be a southern thing
I guess isolated to link that actually
yes - so they're dead I you know I told
you this I want to get into the the
mechanisms of writing the epic Rap
Battles because I mean as as we tell you
every time we're like super thankful to
be involved in these things with you
impede and there is it's it's always
amazing it's amazing to be a guest on
something that's like Oh ten million
views right out of the gate you know
that's that's an amazing thing to just
know that there's like there's a
pressure that's off actually I feel like
because there's so much of what we do
that you're just like okay well we're
working so hard on this is it gonna be
worth it I mean do you get that sense at
this point with the success of an epic
rap battle that it's like there's a
you're able to release and say alright
people love this it's it there's a
baseline view that is it's tremendous
does that take a pressure off or does
that add more
I don't know I mean I think it's a
little bit of both like I feel like it's
it's a constant it makes the pressure
constant I think which maybe relieves it
an overall you know because it's like we
don't do that many videos so we have to
put a you know a lot a lot of time into
each one so we just try to give all of
them everything we have definitely some
do better than others for sure I mean
there's like 10 million viewed disparage
disparity disparity thank you thank you
I just turned into your dad they're
different so it definitely it definitely
there's disparity in some of them but I
don't think about is this one gonna be
good or is that one gonna be good I
think more about the characters or if we
have guests like you guys and thank you
for those nice things you said it's
always I mean working with you guys has
been so cool when we first started the
battles we were like oh let's put
together like an ensemble cast and we'll
just keep using the same people over and
over again and we like thought about
casting and doing an audition stuff but
it's kind of become this very organic
kind of ensemble cast that we work with
so it's really nice so I just try to
focus on if there are special guests
like you guys I try to focus on making
you guys the best song that we possibly
can and that takes the pressure off of
like the world stuff because you it's
like just localizes it a little bit
mm-hmm and then but there's also us I
mean there's your own self-imposed
standard I really get a sense that you
guys are you have this internal standard
and I think it's I don't know if this
guy impression is more about that like I
knew you guys worked so hard on crafting
each of these things yeah we definitely
push each other and we definitely know
we only make 12 battles a year so like
we can do we have to do it really really
well
so just start to walk us through the
process like when we were there
recording the vocals like we were
hanging out before we went in to do the
Lewis and Clark vocals and right now
we're just kind of I in the whiteboard
and trying to decipher the process
because it was okay obviously there's
like this collaborative place where
somebody's writing on a whiteboard and
there's like different lines yeah that
are up there like that are there are
comedic concepts how does it how does a
song we do at our
first we do a ton of first we decide on
the matchup obviously is not always a
suggestion always a suggestion but it's
kind of easy now because there's so many
suggestions that if usually there's
something in our brain we just can go
search you search for it yeah yeah yeah
and I mean that's it's a very nice thing
but it's always from the audience but
there's certainly a lot to choose from
so we first decide on that then we
decide usually on a beat the beat will
will influence the style of writing we
try to find a beat that that feels right
for the well let's talk Lewis and Clark
then yeah picking that beat well first
of all you picked Lewis and Clark versus
Bill and Ted let's just walk through
this one since we're so fond of it yeah
like you how did you pick it the beat No
let's loosen concept oh um we picked it
because are you in a room you and Pete
are you on the phone or there other
there's other people at this point
welcome we'll go to the studio with
that's where we usually work you know we
hang out there and you know as we
approach when we map out like the
production time or months or whatever we
have a couple of weeks in there that we
decide on matchups decide on beats and
stuff like that and so during that time
we're just kind of brainstorming there's
usually you usually do about six at a
time and there's usually about three
that we've been talking about and didn't
get to do the the previous season or
whatever that life kind of fit in or one
of us will have our favourites that
we'll just try to get back into the
right into that you know so and when
you're making that decision how much of
it is based on how people are gonna love
this or we're gonna love this and the
reason I ask that is because when you
think about Lewis and Clark and Bill and
Ted I mean first of all in general
history you're already dealing with
things that maybe a lot of kids out
there not gonna know about to begin with
right yeah yeah but then when you're
dealing with like a reference like Bill
and Ted you're also kind of talking to
people America who are Americans who
were thirty thirty years old and up
right yeah technically yeah well I
assume you started with Bill and Ted you
didn't you were like chomping at the bit
to do a Lewis and Clark rap out oh we
knew you guys were gonna we knew you
guys were gonna play loose we knew Bill
and Ted versus Lewis and Clark probably
since like season the beginning of
season three oh really it was always
gonna be you guys that's that's a fact
really
yeah so the fact that you guys are
playing Lewis and Clark or like oh yeah
that's gonna be great so that made that
really exciting what you chose but you
chose a rap battle about Bill and Ted
and then paired them with conceptually
with Lewis and Clark as like the first
step what do you mean like you chose to
pit them against each other the
characters yeah yeah yeah for sure we
chose a matchup first but that matchup
has been around for a long time is right
saying so the matchup has been around
and so like me and Pete knew we could
probably do Bill and Ted and you guys as
Lewis and Clark was super easy so yeah I
mean yeah it's it's like a specific we
try to do 5050 we try to like to stay
true to ourselves and see what's gonna
be funny for us and not try to get to
pander II you know interpretive like Oh
like we don't do like the latest flash
in the pan
you know usually the rule is if they're
gonna be still remembered in 50 years
from now even if it's just by a specific
pocket of people okay like then we'll do
it Lewis and Clark are obviously yeah
they're gonna be there and Bill and Ted
there's I mean Keanu Reeves is still
very you know popular and that other guy
you know yeah did you see John wick as
part of your reconnaissance who knew
Keano moves okay there's my answer no I
saw it I heard it was good it wasn't
good I read it was not as good as it was
it was made out to be
mmm sorry it was better than people
expected it to be before they wrote that
it was better than you expected
right better than Jupiter rising with
Channing Tatum
so Channing Tatum so you finally get
around to to makin this one and like you
know weird we're basically just sitting
on the doorstep just waiting to come in
and like record another and I think I
told you this but one of the first books
that I remember reading as a kid
and crying in my bedroom alone when I
was done reading it was a book about
Lewis and Clark when they finally made
it when they finally made it when you
cried I cried I have never cried because
I've never cried reading a book I mean
grade school kid in my like I don't know
it was just it was a long book it was a
part of my life for a long time
because I'm a I'm a slow reader yeah and
they finally made it you're finally done
with the book and I under 18 months no
one told me they had made it Lloyd I
mean spoiler this is base you were in
the suspense the whole time why would
they have a book about these guys that
they couldn't make it really good try
and they died well he I mean they did
suicide was not part of the book my
grade school loved a version he learned
up from Ken Burns I learned that from
the epic rap battle lyrics nice no I I
learned that from Kim burn I didn't know
I didn't know that until we started
doing a research I didn't know he'd
killed himself until we started reading
about it and stuff so so then you sit
down and you start writing this thing
yeah I start Pete and I obviously have a
very different not obviously we have
very different styles of writing and
almost everything that we do okay so
Pete well the first thing we'll do is
just start brainstorming you know if in
a perfect world now that we're into the
production like we're sort of our heads
all over the place and we're like
piecing things together but like when we
come into it relaxed and good we'll have
me and Pete and sometimes Zak and Mike
another writer of ours and we'll just
toss around ideas what are the things
that you would want to know about Bill
and Ted what are the what are the top 10
things you think of right away what are
the middle 10 things we have this kind
of SAT a CT way of writing things which
is like three tiers of jokes and in a CT
or SATs you have like three tiers of
questions one that everybody will get
mid-level B is like you know a couple
people will get and then I mean like a
more average people get and then C is
like a really niche only superfans will
get so well not let me ask you are you
describing it that way to us or is that
how you talk amongst yourselves when
writing to like we've got our three
tiers and are there three tiers on a
white board or is this just we don't we
don't get that structured with it that's
just what we have in our brain and we
talk about it that way when we talk
about the writing you want to be able to
categorize a joke to know that you've if
you've got a whole song full of third
tier jokes or you want to even
dispersion jokes yeah you want you want
to be able to if someone's never seen
Bill and Ted you want them to be able to
understand from watching it and seeing
it that it's funny but then you also
have to have those jokes that the Bill
and Ted super uber fans will love yeah
and in the middle
Oh jokes that like I'm kind of familiar
with that Rufus guy yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so well what was that you know
you're gonna get this Sacagawea like
joke in there
it's the question how one of the best
one of the best not Sacagawea yes if
it's one of the best so your so you're
starting with comedic concepts
categorized on a whiteboard there's no
there's no rhyming pairs I mean I saw it
for for another one yeah not yet no
couplets yet usually you know we'll just
kind of be like okay these are fun this
is good this is good this is good yeah
you should know that and then out of
that usually some sort of rhyme will
come out like if you say Sacagawea
summer be like what rhymes that's a fun
word what rhymes with that usually we'll
do that for a while and break away and
start writing on our own like writing
jokes together crafting jokes do you
divide up who's writing what are your
like you're both working on the same
thing I'm independently it's gotten
really really varied like you guys's
verse like in the in past songs like in
the Ninja Turtles like Pete wrote the
first part of the artists and then I
wrote like the middle part then he wrote
the back and then I wrote the front end
of Ninja Turtles and here at the front
end and and then the other guys are like
punching in jokes and punching up jokes
and like anybody in the room could be
saying something Dante will say
something or you know how many people
are in that process at that point when
you're in the room four or five yeah
usually four or five and then and then
usually it's it comes down to me and
Pete one night late like just punch it
okay I'm really gonna dig into the when
you go into the room by yourself because
I mean it's fascinating for us because
we also do this you know and first of
all we're not gonna both go into a room
and write the same verse because then
that's double work yeah we're gonna
divide this thing up yeah yeah yeah so
yeah you look crazy I don't want to
create any more work if he's gonna write
something I'm for sure not gonna also
write it right and and risk it not being
used well we don't we don't do that way
like we'll divide it up especially if
I'm playing a character in peace playing
a character will
spend a lot of time writing each our own
character right he does a lot more of
the mixing and a lot more of the like
costuming and stuff than I do so I at
times I'll need to carry a little bit
more weight on the writing and then just
the writing side okay and then it always
changes once you go into the studio to
record it anyway so I have when I used
to write back in the day we used to butt
heads a lot more with everybody I used
to like write these jokes and really
fall in love with them and really have
them be precious and be like it would be
like a big argument when we were trying
to change them and now I write things
and I and I think it's I think about 85%
of it will will stay once again at first
like as it gets down farther and farther
at sit closer but like we've changed the
entire back ends of the song in the
studio on the mic in the headphones just
because it wasn't just wasn't feeling
right for some reason just wasn't going
but when you okay but when you're like
in there writing your piece like you you
wrote the beginning of Lewis and Clark
Lewis and Clark
yeah keep going used to be we blazed a
trail and it used to be blazer trails
but then we use blaze a trail later on
in the song blaze twice can't blaze
twice so they cut a path through him
Steve liked the works better now so
that's what I want to know cuz you're
you're sitting it you've got jokes
that's how we start to we we have jokes
we used to fall in love with like that
sounds good and then no one cared if it
wasn't funny but the thing that you got
I'm always in all you guys is how
amazing the flows are I mean there's a
level of artistry it's so difficult to
bake comedy into something that sounds
so legitimate I mean it's not comedy
music it's I mean you're making usually
you usually have to make a compromise
yeah yeah and one one direction or the
other and so how does that how does that
work I mean there's this really I mean
you I know because I've had to learn it
I've actually tried to do it a lot right
and that's create something that has an
amazing flow that I would actually sound
like an actual rapper well I want to see
that comment yeah
because those were my heroes as a kid
right
so I would I just want one comment and
thousands to say well I was that
actually a good flow thanks but you I
mean you you you obviously give a lot
you devote a lot of effort to that
because it it shows but how do you do
that I mean you're sitting there saying
well I I mean I always whenever I
started rapping as an escape from comedy
so I never considered my I never wanted
to do comedy rap and I consider the Rap
Battles comedy but no more comedy than
any other rap battle is it's just more
understandable and digestible because
everybody understands the context so I I
don't really consider myself a comedy
rapper if you look at any of the
original music that I do it's all
hip-hop and it's none of it's really
funny so I do write it just like a
regular rap song and then you know in in
in coming up with the flows I think
that's the that's the kind of the art of
being an emcee and being you know it's
it's like skiing or slaloming or
something or surfing or figuring out how
you want to like the beat is that double
dutch you know and you just got to
figure out what your whoo up is once you
get inside of there and then so I just
that's why the beat is so important and
and it's it's hot it's tough to write
the track without the beat first because
bump it up and up and up and up and up
but uh but I put up put up put up on a
papa rod that can start to sound really
really really like repetitive after a
while so and back in the day when we
used to write you can hear it too we
were you know we've grown as you get but
you can hear the jokes split it up you
can hear it's like setup punchline then
setup punchline okay and now as we've
evolved you get longer verses that kind
of flow and they're all blended together
a little bit better right when you can
get when you can get that I mean boy we
back in the day we would have maybe
three setup lines for one punch line you
know like in you and you just hear it
it's just like throw away so I just just
just to get there but it but it's
interesting that I hear you saying that
it's not even you're not even doing
setup punch line anymore really I mean
there's some of those in there but
that's not really the appropriate
everything's a joke I mean everything's
ooh it's well as social everything is
purposeful yeah mmm everything's its
punchline punchline that's how we do it
what an interesting thing is is it you
may have forgotten this but I remember
the first time Pete sent us the
super-marv
brothers and right brothers you know you
know we were the Wright brothers and he
sent us the lyrics and he he sent us a
lyric tunas let you know let me he kind
of had a little bit of a you know let me
know if you have any thoughts or kind of
thing and so we were just kind of
assuming that this is probably like a
lot of the collaborative videos that we
had done in the past we kind of wanted
to like do our due diligence to kind of
make it our own and that kind of thing
so we I didn't know what he meant by
give us any notes and so we like kind of
came back with we think we should
probably say this here this year had
like having no insight really into like
the machine that had and it was a little
bit less of a develop machine at that
time sure but I can't remember his
response word for word but it was a it
was basically no we're not gonna do that
and now hearing this conversation of
course and we would never in a million
years would we have done that on the
second or the third because it's so it's
gone through this process and it's
gotten to be exactly what you guys want
to do but it was more we were kind of
approaching it from that oh yeah some
youtubers collaborating together we we
should probably give our thoughts on
this just because we're being a part of
it but now there's like this going into
that process when we get that you know
your guys demo track yeah I'm like how
can I make it is much like what they
have presented it's gonna be me being
yeah it's like don't say you know it's
like a director that yeah really good
director who you can trust the script
you know you're not supposed to change
the script because that's how they work
I mean that is how you guys put so much
into it yeah it's there's there's no
need to it's not we're not gonna riff on
this thing we're gonna improv my way
into something better that's for sure
yeah I mean we thank you for all those
nice things it's really cool of you guys
I say I think that's always been our
goal is to I mean to we understand how
busy most people that we work with are
so like and I've been on the opposite
side of that when someone sends you
something you're like yeah I can't
really work with this and now I feel
really awkward that I have to kind of go
in there and do this so our goal was
always to like try to blow people away
with the demo but when you're writing
for Snoop Dogg yeah I mean it
point you cut I mean we learned a lesson
fer we learned a big lesson from really
and it was uh like the I don't know what
it was empowering I guess cuz we wrote
the lyrics but we never sent him a demo
and he was playing Moses again so Santa
I love that bear scratch up my head a
little bit on now but we didn't send him
a demo we just sent him the lyrics cuz
we were like that's Snoop Dogg he's one
he'll figure he wants to do he'll fit
and he was used to him instrumental we
said on the instrument on the lyrics and
we sent him the Santa part and we're
just two holes in his part there are no
vocals for his part right and and he was
joking around like this my these do is
they're messing with me they didn't even
send me a demo they just make me
freestyle on this thing so we were like
we took out of that oh and it was like a
sort of a light bulb more like of course
like so like as least work as a guy
that's not busy has it has got to be
send him that and then if he wants to
change it of course he'll change it but
like so he came in and that was the the
flow that he had come up with her he
asked for the demo later he didn't we
never got to track with him he just went
to his own private basement studio with
his guy and the send us didn't worked a
song so it was still awesome yeah but
like I think he was just he just thought
that was funny that we didn't send it to
him we were like oh man we didn't want
to step on your toes but you know but
you never did you heard this after he
had come up with the flow and everything
yeah so you put snoop to work well we do
make a demo we made a demo so you put
snoop to work and and was this better oh
man I mean don't just don't answer this
yeah I didn't know it was so smooth you
have to say yes we got you on tape we
got it on tape that when we first they
sent it over and it was like we
downloaded this file we're like we're
gonna hear snoop saying our stuff yeah
and we have the whole video we're gonna
put it in the BTS but we don't know we
didn't get in there for some reason but
it was just like that's been cool so for
Lewis and Clark you get to this point
where you know that all right they've
discovered a whole bunch of stuff uh-huh
and so what are you gonna do with that
yeah we thought like in that you know
that like sort of roundtable discussion
on second thought
cool too like for them to like the list
off a bunch of stuff and then I went
online and I did like I did like a
search for I know Lewis and Clark
animals and there was like this one page
that listed off all the animals that
they discovered and it was really it was
like a long you're like I bet somebody's
rise illegal yeah that number arrived
with weasel an eagle I think yeah cuz it
does man yes
so that's Zach the guy who played
Einstein he's he's like the most award
Smith of us all like he's the best in
terms of like like syllables and and the
the crafting of a word that comes
together so for that section
I sent him that link and the idea and
and then he sent back like three
different versions of a list and then I
took what he took what he wrote and I
like kind of worked it into the beat in
like so it changed probably like 30
percent more and so that's how that
process really nice it's like a handing
off of you know the ball to each other
quite a bit
so it's really it's it's a nice
collaborative process we want to get
back to but we want to go back to the
Lloyd the pre epic Rap Battles of
History Lloyd and figure out how you
became this guy okay
and that takes us back to New Hampshire
yeah yeah born there no I would be born
in Staten Island New York okay
mm-hmm so I was born in New York and I
moved to New Hampshire and I was like
three or two and I spent like all of
high school and you know up through high
school graduate high school from New
Hampshire and then I found two brothers
my older brother Kirk on my own go
brother Travis so the middle brother
what's the dynamic there um I got lost
in the mix know it lost in the mix in
the mix I got to be a little bit of both
because my younger brother is eight
years younger than me oh so how was the
younger brother for like the first eight
year so that was cool I have a great
relationship with both of those guys
they're great I'm gonna be an uncle soon
my little brothers having a baby baby
girl so I'm gonna go down he lives in um
how Florida how old is the older brother
than you
I mean Kirk is a year and a half older
than me so was he the one who was like
bringing the rap tapes in a house
no no really not at all that's not my
brother
jerk how did I get into rap I got into
rap I'm not I'm not
my memories not real good and I don't
I'm not like I'm not there's like
different types of people you know and
I'm not like a cataloger like I can't I
can't remember any words to any lyrics
oh really any song the only I really I
wrote a line about that the only words
to rhymes I remember our mind and I
forget those a lot too so I wasn't like
I was into like all kinds of music and
then I really started getting into rap
probably like in college oh okay when I
started doing improv we we did it we did
one like little improv game that was a
freestyle rap game we'll what if we
freestyle rap that would be super
amazing so we started doing that but it
was cut but it was comedy first it was
but then it became very quickly about
like freestyling and ciphers at parties
what I mean and like and then then
because we would do these freestyle
sessions like other guys who were
rhymers would start to hang out so I
would start hanging out with those type
of guy that's more and then so were you
a so were you a performer from a younger
age was that like something in your
blood that was a thing I play Bilbo bag
is in the sixth grade play oh really
yeah carry feet and everything yeah well
I did get that middle her brother like I
he was in high school plays and I said
then I started doing play suppose I was
a gymnast all throughout college in high
school so I was much more of like a jock
than then that ring SID
yeah rings yeah like yeah I can tell you
on some rain horse mm-hmm yeah really
yeah dang could you what could you do do
on rings right now we had a set almost
nothing I think I could probably do a
handstand
that's not like it's not like shooting a
basketball it's not like you can't be
like 55 years old I can still shoot mmm
I need like the Rings it's tough yeah so
you did that from a young age if you're
like doing the the gymnast thing it's
it's like kid indoctrination yes like it
owns your life if you're like it you're
trying to be an Olympian right yeah well
though it's definitely much more like a
I think you practice a lot I practice a
lot more than like most sports is just
like after school you play for a couple
hours and you go home this was like we
would have to a days and summer and we
you know it was
like from 3 to like 9 everyday you know
and Saturdays - and then like you know
when she got into college we didn't
really get Christmas and you know it was
it was intense it was Division 1 so it
was where'd you go to school
UMass Amherst oh really and do you as a
gymnast do you do everything or is it
like you know he's he's the rings guy I
was an all around her up until I got in
and once you get to college they start
to specialize you but there is a
specialized one called all around so
guys who especially do that I started I
hurt my that's how I ended up getting
into comedy as I blew my knees out so I
was able I had extra time to take like
the acting classes that I always wanted
to take was it just like a matter of
deteriorating over time was there like
an injury where yeah having probably
gnarly accent tell us about it in detail
well your knees are like a degenerative
thing so they're attached your knee is
definitely the Achilles heel of the
human body so there it's attached the
Achilles heal me but once you hurt your
knee it's easier to hurt it again you
know so I started I was a wrestler there
was at one point in high school when I
would wake up at 5:00 in the morning go
do diving then do school then wrestle
after school and then go from wrestling
practice to gymnastics practice so in
the state tournament of wrestling this
guy shooting shot in on my knee and like
hit it sideways so I don't like it
called it was called a subluxation so I
like slid out with a sock of them back
in then I pinned his ass and couldn't
move on because my niece will up so you
were it made you mad like it hurt that
bad that you were like he is not gonna
beat me he's not I was not a changed my
life trajectory but he's not gonna win
this match that's really weird
but then that that that's then I started
that hurt my knee in gymnastics once and
then in college I was doing this trick
where you saw on floor you you know what
a roundoff is it's like forward momentum
in the back it's like a cartwheel your
legs come together so you do a roundoff
and then it's called a whip backhand
which is like a really fast flip and
then you do another flip out of that but
I rolled my ankle in the whip back so I
rolled my right angle in the whip back
and then I flung over and I remember in
the mid air I was like oh that hurt my
ankle thank God that wasn't my knee I
literally thought that and then when I
landed I just landed side my whole knee
so I have two screws in my left knee so
I rehabbed that for a year and I was on
crutches for like seven months and then
I got back and I got back competing
again and I blew my right and yeah tore
my ACL my right knee on parallel bars so
then after that that was it hello
how would you tear a knee on a parallel
bar dismounting I was doing a like a
layout with like a double twisting
layout off and so I landed I was still
spinning and I'm like you know you kind
of turn into the ground it was it was
just very like demoralizing yeah after
everything you'd been through with the
recovery and then it's the other knee
and then it's not even the same knee
yeah it was tough but that's what opened
up everything for comedy but how low did
it get at that moment I mean is it like
what were you planning on doing it was
this was it it was it a it was it was it
was almost a blessing because I wasn't
gonna be in the Olympics you know what I
mean like I wasn't the coaching wasn't
good enough I hadn't been doing it long
enough I didn't have enough you know
there's this you know at that point
whether you're gonna be in the Olympics
right so it was almost a blessing like
because it was taking up so much of my
time and I didn't really love it you
know what I mean it's like you almost do
it out of obligation you do it out of
like a lifestyle cause it's kind of what
you've always done but it's your world I
mean yeah but I didn't love it and then
I started doing this improv stuff and I
could hide but what was that choice if
it was that a switching track so were
you just doing that on the side so it
was like well I was doing it on the side
but when I got hurt I had more time you
know what I mean because you rehab but
like your practice is like six hours a
day but if you're hurt you know you
rehab for an hour too but I could do
plays I could do this improv stuff at
night you know it's they was like a show
at 7:00 or something I could do it so I
just was able to do I was doing these
improv shows on crutches you know really
that's how I met my what you like yeah
were you like incorporating the crutch
into all your like characters yeah a
little bit I would were you already kind
of funny like a guy that was just like
Oh along to my friends I'm a funny guy
like maybe I should do improv or I want
to be funny so I'm gonna do improv um
that is a funny thing to say I never
thought about doing comedy ever
you know high school I was I was like a
talkative and charismatic guy probably a
little bit funny but I never thought I
always thought it would be like serious
acting and stuff and then I did this
improv exercise in a college class and
it went really well and then we went to
a improv show that night as a class and
this kid was happened to sitting next to
me being like oh you should join this
group they just had an audition on
campus so I went and did that and that's
how I got into doing comedy and what
yeah yeah what do you have that makes
you good at improv personally I have
there are two types of improvisers
there's like two categories there's
heart players and head players and head
players use their mind to protect their
heart so and they make funny witty sharp
jokes their intellectual players I'm
very very pure heart and character
player so much I don't I'm not like I
said I don't remember lyrics I can't
really I can't make a lot our deep
references or anything but I can react
and Anna mote and play pretty honestly
and I'm pretty physical and I think that
helps but yeah and definitely Rap
Battles has helped me be a lot better at
characters which usually plays pretty
good to it I don't I don't mean to make
this about us but I'm just trying to
process having never taken an improv
class but talking to talk to a number of
people who come from that world I'm very
fascinated with it because it I mean we
do a lot of improv and we just kind of
feel our way through it
yeah and even in deciding how we want to
take a particular episode we're having a
conversation this morning about who
should lead and who should react
depending on things obviously okay who's
ahead and who's the heart that's pretty
it I mean it's there's a blurred of the
line obviously yeah if you have to
categorize us it's pretty obviously rets
more of a head guy and I'm more of a
heart guy yeah the thing about I don't
but I'm also the guy who like remembers
all the lyrics I don't think that I
think that's a totally different thing
that's a totally different part of my
brain but like if you tell me to
remember a line or like you got to
deliver this in this way or I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm a singing with this one
yeah it's like I'm gonna I'm gonna flop
rap he learned in second grade yeah
right off the top yeah but if it's a
which I can't do it all just come in and
I give
I'll just I'll give you an honest
reaction and like maybe it'll be funny
you know it's kind of a like even when I
said that voice was that fun yeah you're
deaf well it's like this it's like this
thing I know I almost wrote a book about
improv one time this is like head and
heart and character itself so are you
making this stuff up is this your are
these your principles that would be in
your book yeah
that would really yeah the head in the
heart this is your thing yeah okay yeah
I think so that's what I would well I
wrote a curriculum at the Iona's comedy
theater and there's a training center
and I wrote a curriculum for the there's
like six levels of classes there and
it's changed a little bit since then but
I wrote the first curriculum and you
know you have six levels improv and you
go through it's you know but head and
heart and character and self so the
other thing I don't know how much in
Perm you've seen but like some people
play some people play themselves on
stage most of the time like they're like
a version of like a Kevin Costner or
Harrison Ford you know like the
improvisers are the same way like
they're not gonna they don't change the
way they improvise too much and then
there's guys like like I think I'm more
this way you probably this way too it's
like much more character based like big
shapeshifter yeah like a Johnny Depp or
like a Tom Hardy or somebody like that'd
like Polly really goes the other way but
you can have a guy who's like a
character player which is big and out
there but he can also play from his mind
you know and I mean which is what I
think probably you would do if you're
like for a fairly cerebral guy but does
characters that's what you would do yeah
I don't think I'm a mind guy at all I
think I'm a heart guy first full heart
whatever I'm all heart whatever is gonna
whatever is gonna come out more
calculated it is the more it probably
ain't gonna work yeah for me that's cool
that's what you mean yeah maybe that's
maybe that's true have to get you guys
in an improv class and find out well
yeah we've we've talked we definitely
talked about it because it's something
almost everything we do is just pure
instinct and not and it's just the if
there's any sort of curriculum it's just
something that we discussed amongst our
ourselves we discover you guys have been
friends for so long yeah that's that
that helps right so valuable so so I
want it cuz you know I don't think a lot
of people love you mean I know that that
you that you own this comedy theater so
this is a big part of who you are in
your life so it really highlights that
that pivotal moment where you switched
over to kind of go back
that yes so you so you're you're trying
improv for the first time and then where
does that go
I met oh say so I was in college I
auditioned for this improv thing on
crutches I met a guy named Aaron Krebbs
who I still work with today on the
theater with today and got into this
improv group started improv this is
where it you mass okay you man and you
mastered the first year there I was like
hanging out with all the jocks and all
like the jock guys cuz that's where I
was I was and I didn't really never felt
like I fit in I just didn't get I didn't
I didn't have like they would like like
bust each other's balls all the time and
really you know how I don't know there's
certain people like they could be
friends with you but they're like
they're macho kind of didn't get I
didn't like that so I ended up meeting
these improv dudes and we got along
really well I finally had this clique of
friends and we started like doing these
shows and doing a show every week and
the audiences groom groom grew then we
started touring a little bit and there
was six of us guys who really clicked
six of us and so after I got hurt in
college that was my junior year at the
end of the year three of those six guys
were gonna graduate and then the group
was kind of gonna fall apart
so I was like after this so I me and
Aaron got drunk on a 12-pack of Corona
and he was gonna go to New York City and
like take a job like a bank or something
for like 40 grand a year which at that
time was a lot but I was like man we got
to get out of here we got to get out of
here what are we doing let's go do this
so we're like alright so I dropped out
of college convinced two other guys to
drop out of college and then the other
three guys who graduated we all got in a
van that summer we packed all of our
stuff into a van and we drove together
to Chicago in a van rented a big house
you talked all the five other guys three
of which we're graduating they needed
direction the other two needed to be
redirected yeah and so you were like
let's go
did you get any phone calls from angry
parents know that everybody was super
supportive everybody was like I think
they knew they could tell there was
something special about that thing what
was your name cuz you got a name my name
agent snake eyes well I've met the whole
group yeah
its mission is still is mission
improbable yeah probable mi is Westside
comedy theater mission and probable
suicide comedy theater they just think
agent Snickers you better believe it
GI Joe reference I didn't know you all
had to have individual names yeah again
and that's more of a rapper thing yeah
you know and yeah and I was that's it
that was me like when I was in the
beginning like now guys have names like
agent knuckle sandwich or pool like
agent like ham and cheese or whatever
but I was like no man the show's funny
enough we should have cool names like
agent snake Eyez Falcon or hurricane or
a destro until you moved into one house
once a star tan
that's who agent Zartan yeah Alvie your
Dreadnoks sir oh yeah and when you when
you good to Chicago did anybody know
anything about Chicago
no you just knew this was like the
improv capital of yeah we had we had a
festival at our College and we brought a
group from Chicago there to perform and
do it workshops and we met a woman named
Liz Allen and she became like our guru
and so he moved there became a like
started studying we did like group
meetings we had like a Monday business
meeting and then a Wednesday rehearse on
a Friday rehearsal and we'd all take
classes at i/o or Second City we just
lived and breathed and dinner and how
are you paying for this at that point
work and waiting tables one guy was like
a assistant to an EMT one guy did a temp
job and what what were you doing I was
waiting tables that yeah restaurant
bartending yeah and yeah and then one by
one we moved to Chicago and then some of
the guys peeled off you know they're not
all with us anymore but me and air and
the guys who started the plates the
thing which I saw him last night just
shows like you guys I've known that guy
longer than I haven't no no and then
that's how I met Pete so after we were
in shock you met Pete in Chicago
met him in Chicago freestyle rapping on
a porch in the house yeah Pete was like
he was just itinerant right he could
have been anywhere from what I remember
of his story yeah he was represented
biscuit if you want today he was trying
to figure things out for himself at the
same time he was he was in Chicago
studying comedy like a lot of guys and I
didn't even really know him at first as
a musician I didn't know he was a music
guy at all but he was on a porch what
this house that we had it was like this
3 16 15 west Byron it was like we would
throw these giant improv
that's what we did when we got to the
community we're like well it's drag so
we throw like these kegger six seven
kegs and like and like we came from that
we kind of brought that vibe and a lot
of the guys in Chicago at that time were
kind of nerdy kind of impish improvisers
and we just brought this party element
he just got everybody involved and it
was really fun and so we there was like
this back out what everybody would smoke
and stuff and we were out on the port's
just in doing that freestyle thing that
we had been doing since college and you
know it was me and my buddy Reece and
Jeff would my other buddy Hobie and then
there was this other kid who could
actually rap and usually if there was
not a lot of guys who could rap as good
as us cuz we were we had been doing it
for a couple of years yeah and Pete was
there like in his own little thing and I
was like so that's how we met yeah and
then but you didn't immediately begin
working together at that point no a
mission of probables started touring we
would tour colleges and then after we
toured like I toured for about four
years and then it gets really hard but
there's improv is great cuz you can do
the same format because it's a different
show every time so we started hiring out
like second crews and so Pete became one
of the guys we hired as a second crew so
he you know he as one guy got married
and had a kid or whatever couldn't tour
anymore like we would bring other guys
on so Pete and I toured together doing
the mission of probable show for a
couple years and that you know I learned
he played guitar we started making some
music together
and then when I came out here he came
out about a year later and we just
stayed in touch and the rap battles
would started as a live show at the
Westside comedy theater okay so you came
out here first and so how did the whole
Chicago thing wrap up and then what made
you come to LA Aaron the guy that I
started with was always very set he's
from Texas so I guess it's closer or
whatever he knew what it was like but he
was like I'm gonna go to Chicago LA so
he moved out first it was like this gray
area cuz we would be touring I'd only be
home like three months out of the year
so it's like you never really had a
place where you were staying anyway but
like he moved out there first and then
our other buddy Jason moved out there
and then just one by one we started to
like I'm a tricky because we knew like
improv is great but it doesn't have that
it's you got to do something with it you
know you got to write something or do a
show there was no internet at that time
there was no it was either get on TV or
SNL or you don't so we were like all
right we better go to LA
and you know that's where what we want
to do is biggest so you never thought
about doing a theater that wasn't the
idea was like write a TV show okay right
you you wanted to take the traditional
path which is like improv and then move
into traditional entertainment yep and
then where did Josie come into this when
Josie had a show in South Dakota yeah so
their help the co South Dakota she's in
Wyoming but she went to school in South
Dakota so yeah she was uh I would with
my comedy stylings and so that was
during one of the trips one of the tour
- one of the tours yeah there's a
picture of me because they're like the
contacts at the schools will like hire
the groups or whatever and they'll be
like Student Activities boards of like
students who work on these cruise or
whatever so there's a Josie was like the
lead on that show this is a picture of
me meeting Josie the first night me
Josie Pete and all the guys and we're
like hanging out it's like the first
night I ever met my wife that's cool
yeah it's kind of nice yeah and okay so
eventually anyone was that when'd you
meet her how long except that was jeez
nine 2003 okay and then you guys got
married when not 2009
so we've been married just over four
years no that's that's six years old no
yeah no thank you keeps going to time we
were married for five years so whenever
that is I think oh god sorry babe we'll
edit that out we won't maybe we will so
Pete moves to to LA uh-huh and you guys
give her together and say let's let's
start this did it start his epic Rap
Battles of History was that that was no
his first ideally accident it was a
complete accident
because I never even like I didn't watch
online videos before the rap battles
like my second video was Vader Hitler so
I wasn't like like into it you know I
didn't grow anything the rap battle
started inside of a live show called
check one two so it was me and Zach who
I met on the road and he was a another
guy that we would rap with all
time and when he moved to LA I was like
we should do a like a comedy freestyle
rap show so he made this show called
check one two and it was like an hour
show and have like five minute long
segments and you know it was like hold
up your stuff and we would rap about
some of these keys rap about whatever
like what's your name rap about rat or
rap about link and then one of the one
of the segments was a celebrity rap
battle okay and we we would get to
suggestions from the audience and would
be okay Barbra Streisand versus Lionel
Richie and then we would go off and put
these fake necklaces on me like
everybody knows is a long-standing beef
between Barbra Streisand and Lionel
Richie people are getting shot no one
can get out their house we're gonna
bring it now to the stage we're gonna
squash the beef in this rap battle so
then we would freestyle rap battle and
Pete came and saw that show it is just I
mean ought to completely improv and how
often does it not work about 50% of the
really failed about fifty point eight
come up with some cool stuff when it
fails how would you deal with that well
you make when you're watching a show the
audience understands that it's really
hard so yeah yeah as long as you have
charisma you can keep going you're fine
it's just about not being them you can't
lose confidence and just go into
yourself how important is it for it to
rhyme it which is more important than
like oh I said some funny or that
actually right it has to rhyme right one
guy one guy can get away with it if like
if it's like so me versus as a joke as a
joke
but one guy has to be able to put it
together so you can do without a beat
like if you watch Rap Battles online a
lot of the rap battles they don't have
beats so you can kind of like it's it's
stretch it out stretch it out it's not
you don't have to be as articulate so we
would do both but I told that you know I
kept talking about this rap show with
pikas he and I used to freestyle a lot
and I told him about about this segment
and he had just started with maker cuz I
got a I got an email at the theater from
a gentleman named Benny fine and I still
have it saved and he was looking for
writers or comedy people for this
upstart company that they were doing
where they would take youtubers and put
him and help him collaborate together
that was the station at the beginning
and I saw maker
eventually became maker nos Disney so I
sent Pete over there and they hired him
as like
little songwriters so you got pee-pee
toes is almost his whole life as five
brothers you just blindly as the as the
as a theater opener yeah yeah and then
you send Pete over there yeah yeah and
then Pete started doing YouTube and
getting really into that and then when
he saw the the show he was like I love
this segment do I think we should do a
video of it I think we should call epic
Rap Battles of History and we'll ask
like the audience you know whatever and
I was like all right whatever but yeah
sure come over after work or whatever
because he had made other videos he was
making his like picture songs and yeah
and he was getting going
who's doing the music with comedy thing
yeah yeah yeah and at that time if if
you got a thumbs-up from shaycarl or
Kassem G that could change your whole
world you know and they were doing that
at the station and a maker so he was
like I think we should do this rap
battle thing and then so we wrote the
song we picked a beat we wrote the song
pretty quick and then I went in then who
was it which one wasn't John Lennon
versus Bill O'Reilly and then I met Dave
Dave Meharry was the third and very very
emotion very not most important very
important part of this Dave came up with
because I had done videos before I was
like whatever usually was like a
whatever but I walked in did the thing
it was cool when we did this rap thing
and then I left and then like maybe a
week later they sent me this cut and I
was like whoa that is far better than I
thought it was going to be huh it was
just now was just this was just the
track this is nobody videos like a rough
cut of the video okay okay so it had all
this stuff going on and it was like all
this it was just engaging right away I
knew it was something pretty cool and
Dave had edited it Dave had edited
majority of it and he you know he came
up with the logo even you know and you
know and now Dave is at SNL right mm-hmm
okay so so that's where it started and
then yeah that's so you were like I'm a
nun back in I'm gonna come back in for
another one of these let's keep doing
this yeah I mean that was it was the cuz
it was how big was that what everyone
hater Hitler was - number two - yeah
right so that's the one that really took
off yeah
but it didn't take I mean the first one
I remember looking on Petes channel
being like mom in the video I'm there's
like the second must be Journal P on
Petes channel it's pretty cool it was
like four or five hundred thousand views
which was good but then Vader Hitler
went really really big and then then we
kind of followed it up with Norris and
Abe Lincoln and that I think the fact
that we did three of them in a row that
were pretty good mm-hmm
they were all good but they were you
know it never got really corny it never
got really cheesy that the concept held
and also maker was like on this
trajectory and YouTube itself was like
it was like all at the crest of this
wave right there and I was like mm eight
or nine or whatever we were all kind of
you guys to like there it was all
growing really quickly so it just got
happened and then so by episode 8 I quit
the theater or I left I didn't you know
I was like hey I gotta go do this thing
and then I started working on rap
battles full-time what's your favorite
personal performance like that's I
really I'm Italian and I really enjoyed
playing Al Capone yeah I feel like it
was like I feel like I owed it to my
people you know so I enjoyed that and I
think that people enjoyed me as that
character which really felt it felt good
to do that because it was nerve-wracking
I really you know you afterward oh yeah
the Capone family I think that I have to
say Hitler to some extent because that
character has been so good to us is it I
got an email Hitler I feel like I don't
know if I mean I feel like I can I can
play that version of Hitler in places
that you shouldn't be able to play sort
of like Germany thing so right I really
loved Walter White I really loved
hannibal lecter this last time that we
did I'm really loving some of the
battles that were we have coming in the
new six I saw some pictures so excited
me yeah like a tough guy guys I like the
tough guy character right I guess that's
always been my thing
maybe it's the athlete I mean but it's
those guys and one of the things that
you you've done is you've you know
you've developed your own online
presence apart from ER be with epiclloyd
channel you and what I don't know how
many you're doing anymore but one of the
really enjoyed all the ones that you
have done earth at dis wraps
yeah for
yeah tell us about how the idea came
about first of all I apologize to
everybody out there for not doing more
of these I really wish I could and it's
not that I don't want to do them I just
I don't know and maybe you I don't know
how you guys do all the videos that you
do I I just haven't had time to sit down
and like punch one out or like write on
so so I came this transfer hire came
from me it's a kid when there used to be
like your front page of YouTube or
whatever it was like that front page and
a kid just wrote me I started putting up
little raps and stuff like that but a
kid wrote me and was like hey my older
brother has been picking on me his
name's Charles he's he's got a weird
Guido mustache and he never likes any of
the food on his plate to touch but he
picks on me all the time you won't leave
me alone
he's right a rap destroying him yes sir
this yeah so I came up with this idea
like I was like that sounds fun you know
it was like and it felt like the type of
thing and then it felt like the type of
thing that if you liked a rap battle you
might like this no I was like a good
example of a successful sort of spin-off
I was able to drop little hints about
the battle in this raps videos so people
would be like on the chopper what's that
thing
so you ripped Charles a new one I did
ripped so so you still want to get back
to doing those yeah more awesome I mean
what what's the what's the main thing I
mean there's the epic Studios web series
yeah I did it what I'm doing a web
series called epic studios that's
hopefully gonna get produced in early
2016 in Toronto
and that's like a workplace comedy that
is about a guy who inherits a studio
from his dad who gets killed by a lion
don't say y'all so hard so hard to cope
when it is so yeah epic studios did you
write this I wrote it with Aaron the guy
I went to college with and his wife Jill
and wait what's the outlet for this or
um that's TBD still it's like it's
hopefully I think it's gonna be online I
think it's gonna be online but it's it's
still in like the process of maybe
getting maybe getting picked up or not
but hopefully uh that
they're good and is it like you shot a
pilot or we we shot a sizzle reel it's
called like a sizzle reel so we shot a
sizzle reel for that up in Toronto and
it's it's through that in Canada
you get like federal grant money to make
art and stuff so it's like this
application process for that so we're in
like the second or third round of that
so hopefully we're all get picked up
which would be really cool yeah oh so I
pick studios and then just wraps for
hire on the epic Lloyd channel and try
to do that and just original music and
then the big news is the Rap Battles
tour which is in August we start we
start touring them in the middle of
August right after this season gets over
and then we go on tour in the United
States for a month and then we go and
we're going over to Europe so the UK and
France and Spain and a bunch of dates
over there so I'm not really really
excited for can we come yes yeah
absolutely we can come perhaps actually
if we do it if we do a show here yeah
hey we're gonna ask you guys come
perform so did you just ask because we
just said yes I'm talking Spain - I can
swing by Spain yes swing by swing on
Olli yeah I'd love that yeah we got to
practice a little bit more than we did
before we got up there for VidCon and
like started our like Mario Brothers
thing like that's hard at the wrong it's
hard it was very loud we had to start
the song I look at it I'm like looking
over so man like come on wink or
something
we were so mad at ourselves after that
and nobody noticed except and then I
liked it you know I was just me I was
mad we were going back home and her
driving back up to LA from Anaheim and I
was just mad and I texted Pete and was
just like man I feel so bad for not
coming in at the right time we're the
Wright brothers holder we screwed up
Vader
Hitler at playlist Vader Hitler stars
with that
and there's like no just like you got to
click track oh yeah and we put that in
but the click track or the beat is like
the hardest thing to hear when there's
like a big audience or whatever so it's
like I missed it so like it's like the
biggest nightmare ever
aside from Forgetting literally
forgetting the words which I didn't do
thank God but like he was just me be
like all right dude this is fun you got
to sign the table you are it thank you
[Music]
and there you have it our your biscuit
with epiclloyd let him know what you
think tweet at him
the epic Lloyd use hashtag ear biscuits
always appreciate you guys tweeting at
our guests and let them know that what
do you think and what you appreciate
about that conversation as always a
privilege to talk to a guy that is doing
something that is of such a high quality
and you know I gotta say privilege I'm
so privileged I've been looking at the
the comments on the recent rap battle
featuring us at Lane we were in that
remember that and lots of people were
saying I have no idea who these people
are I don't know who Lewis and Clark are
and I don't know who Bill and Ted are
and I got to say what that means first
of all is that a people don't watch
great movies from the 80s B people don't
know history the second point I think we
have influence because well you know I
don't have to tell you that I haven't
seen Bill & Ted's Excellent course sure
of course and what was not supposed to
mention that you're supposed to just let
that you don't need a knowledge that you
don't you're not you don't need to be
part of the problem because you're part
of the solution which is the second
point people don't know history oh I do
know who Lewis and Clark L now think
about it millions of people out there
link the only thing they know about
Lewis and Clark is what we have taught
them as Lewis and Clark when they think
Lewis and Clark they see me in you how
does that make you feel that is the
responsibility we rep
American heroes to kids everywhere
maybe this well if I'd have known that
I've probably been even more nervous
Oh recording booth oh I gotta get this
right but it turned out really great I
think also for the Wright brothers I
mean more people know who the right
person flight more people do know they
you know invented the airplane and then
the North Carroll the Renaissance they
didn't invent in North Carolina I know
they invented it in Ohio and then they
flew it in North Carolina but we don't
care we're gonna take credit for it
because they flew it at Kitty Hawk North
Carolina yeah so it's nice to be a part
of it the educational thrust of hip-hop
music on the Internet
oh really yeah that's one way to think
about it all right guys you know what
we're gonna do we're gonna give you
another one of these next week so open
your hearts open your minds open your
ears for the fish all you have to just
receive it - just lay down right here
and just just put these headphones on
and don't it's getting a little weird
don't think about anything just this is
like the kind of the way you talk to
somebody before you kill them or just
before you put them on it for like
dental work okay count backwards from
ten nine he started a nice
[Music]
[Music]